- I do this thing where I walk on my toes
and it's like a normal thing, like,
I've done it since I was a kid.
- Oh, don't do that.
- I can--
- Even if you can do it, don't.
You're like walking right
on the joint. Ow, ow.
- I keep seeing these posts
about healthcare workers
coming home and avoiding
contact with their families
completely or taking off their scrubs
before walking into their house
so that they don't
spread anything to them.
But I personally feed my
scrubs to my children every day
that I come home from work
because I didn't raise
a family of (cat meows).
Amber Lynn, shut the (cat meows) up.
- What just happened? That was
the most aggressive Tiktok.
Is that a joke?
Yeah, you should absolutely
take off your scrubs
before you see your
family and take a shower.
(rain falling)
Like, the first thing
I do when I come home
is like, shower time.
She said, "I feed it to my children".
I was like, "Oh my God".
- Megan just asked me, "Have
you ever twerked to orchestra?"
(orchestra music plays)
(laughing)
- This is amazing.
Not only because she's truly twerking
to classical orchestra music,
but because they're
clearly having fun at work
and we need a little bit more of that.
I also have so many videos just like this
from my residency days.
(upbeat music)
(laughing)
- Things that don't belong
in your body, part four.
- Part four? I wanna see
parts one through three.
(upbeat music)
I'm fairly sure dumbbells
don't belong in the human body.
The weirdest ones I've seen,
pipe cleaners, like you know,
those little furry ones when
you're a kid, in a male.
And a carrot, I'll leave it at that.
- Hey Becky, I just wanted
to check in with you.
Are you doing okay? Do you need anything?
- Who me? No, I'm fine.
It's actually kind of quiet today.
- (gasps)
(straw sucking air bubbles)
(laughing)
- [Intercom voice] Code
blue. Fourth floor, four D.
- Oh my gosh, it got busy!
(laughing)
- I've said it time and time again.
You do not say the Q word.
It's funny that I'm getting
all stressed out about it.
When I was the guy saying,
"Oh, it's kinda quiet".
10 rapid responses, four
admissions, two code blues.
Oof, oof.
(high pitched car engines)
They took like the most
gangsta driving thing.
I don't even know what
competition this is.
They put piggy noises in the back of--
- Soap is an amazing substance.
Oh, Bill Nye, the Science Guy.
We, by the way, became quite close friends
at the Men in Black premiere.
We actually tried to get
him on the YouTube channel,
still making that happen.
Maybe you guys can exert some forces,
some gravitational-like physical forces,
and encourage him to come on the channel.
Each soap molecule is
like a string with one end
that sticks to water and the other end
that sticks to oil or fat.
So take a look at this.
The string floating on water
represents a Coronavirus molecule.
(Air whooshing)
(bell dings)
Watch what happens when we
touch the surface of the water
with this bar of soap.
(beeping noise)
Three, two, one!
(water dripping)
The molecule falls apart.
That's why you've gotta wash your hands,
wash your hands, wash your hands, whew!
Take that, virus molecule.
(dripping water)
Ha ha ha.
- Just so everyone knows that sound effect
is not actually what's happening
when you wash your hands.
Can you imagine how
noisy bathrooms would be?
(high pitched pops)
But yes, soap does destroy the membrane,
thereby killing viruses, bacteria,
and, the added benefit of
washing your hands with soap and
water, getting rid of foreign residue,
dirt and things like that.
- That moment when your doctor's
office calls you and says,
Oh my goodness, we're so sorry.
We forgot the extra
screening that you requested.
Can you come in and do
a urine sample for us?
And then you say, "The extra
screening I requested?"
and they say, "Yes, you wanted
an STD test for chlamydia".
And then you say, "I'm pretty
sure I don't have chlamydia.
I did not request that".
And then they say, "Uh oh".
- That shouldn't happen.
If a patient of the same name
came in at the same time,
and there wasn't a name alert
given either by the system
or by the staff, you have called
back patients incorrectly.
And that can get very, very
problematic 'cause as you know,
healthcare information
is a protected asset.
(upbeat music)
This is the honest truth
behind social media by the way,
look they always look so glamorous
and they're never tired.
Like Dr. Mike, how do you
come home from night shifts
and look like you're wide awake.
I don't, I come home and I crash.
- I need a Tiktok doctor.
Look at it, it's so
weird and inconsistent.
When you're constantly typing,
especially sitting in that
non ergonomic position
where your hand is cocked
backwards like that,
it's quite uncomfortable.
And as a result, when
you overuse a muscle,
especially one that's
under-trained, you can cause spasms,
cramps, and they happen just like that.
(dramatic music)
(laughing)
Nowhere in the world, in the
legitimate medical schools,
do we teach that Himalayan salt lamps
can do anything outside of
maybe a look kind of cool
in your bedroom decor.
'Cause you know, you want a light,
but you also wanna show
that like, you're with it.
You're with the geo,
you're like a geo person.
Do not go on a journey, looking
to boost your immune system
if you have a normal,
healthy immune system.
The definition of homeostasis
in a normal immune system
is one that is not boosted.
Because a boosted immune system
is an auto immune condition
where your body's so boosted
it starts attacking itself.
Don't boost it.
- (indistinct)
- Yep.
(shoes squeaking)
(laughing)
Where's my room?
Just take me to my room!
(laughing)
- Right over here.
- Oh, thanks.
(laughing)
Sometimes, I look at my nurses or CMAs,
and they're bringing patients in,
and sometimes they're like, letting the,
they're being polite.
So they say like, go right
ahead, for the patient
to walk into the general area.
Then the patient has no idea where to go.
- Truth about sunscreen.
Sunscreen is poison, guys.
Do not use sunscreen.
Okay? So this is the truth, now.
- No, it's not.
- Light skinned people are not
supposed to burn in the sun.
When I was younger, I
would burn in the sun.
Now I never burn.
I get five to six hours of sun every day.
I try to at least.
Okay, so, this is the key.
You have to change what you're eating.
What you're eating, if it's acidic based,
and all that junk food and
garbage and all that meat,
it's gonna make it so your
skin burns in the sun.
If you switch to organic
fruits and vegetables,
you're not gonna burn the sun anymore.
- I feel like he's burned right now.
Like, what is he talking about?
Do not even experiment with this.
If you go outside, you will get a sunburn,
if you're in the right place, with the sun
hitting you for an
extended period of time.
And guess what?
With each burn that you have,
you are more likely to
develop a skin cancer.
And one of the most deadly and scary
skin cancers are melanomas.
Well, if you get a melanoma
and you don't catch it,
and it spreads, melanoma
spreads to the most random
of places; muscles,
bones, liver, your eyes,
your neurological system,
please wear your sunscreen.
And don't listen to Jimmy B
Rose TV or whoever this is.
- We want nice, steady compressions.
- What?
- Look at Trent. That's
CPR that'll save a life.
(upbeat music)
- Oh thanks. I used to be a lifeguard.
(screaming)
- What happened?
- What did you do?
- I don't know!
- Where am I?
- You were too good at CPR!
- Ha ha!
I wonder if I did my chest
compressions, chest compressions,
chest compressions, can I
bring the dummy back to life?
I actually prank doctors,
click here to check that out.
Like, legit. Like, you're
gonna see their faces.
They got pranked. Mama Dr.
Jones is in it, spoiler alert.
But click it to check it out,
and as always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)